hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american psychological
thriller film called run
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the film begins with a team of doctors
trying to save the life of a premature
newborn baby
a few moments later the baby's mother
diane sherman
is called to see the condition of her
baby who has passed the critical phase
and she asks if the baby would be okay
the scene shifts to a child named chloe
who has five major diseases including
asthma
diabetes and paralysis at home
chloe has a routine of taking many
medicines and checking blood to control
her blood sugar levels
chloe is shown to be a very intelligent
young teenager she has a desire to study
at one of the top universities in the
city
and applies to her college application
with such passion
she is always excited when a letter
comes and hopes that it is a university
acceptance letter
but unfortunately she never gets any
letter from the university
chloe also loves to do experiments and
assemble sophisticated tools that she
taught herself at home
one day when chloe is studying chloe
hears the sound of a car
she thinks it is a male delivery car but
immediately looks out the window and it
turns out to be her mother who has just
come home after buying things
when her mother is on the phone chloe
immediately peeks into her mother's
grocery box and takes some chocolates in
the box
however chloe accidentally sees that
there is one pack of green medicine with
diane sherman's name on it
and naturally chloe is curious about
what disease her mother has
at night chloe's mother gives some
medicine for chloe to take before going
to bed
chloe is surprised because there is a
green medicine she saw before
she queries this to her mother and she
claims that it is chloe's medicine and
the name on the medicine package is only
the recipient's name
chloe who is still astonished continues
to take the medicine and go straight to
sleep
the next day curiosity gets the better
of chloe she decides to take one pack of
the medicine in the medicine cabinet and
looks at the name of the medicine
trigoxin is printed on the package and
she is confused because this time she
sees her name wrapped in the medicine
she peels off a little sticker with her
name and sees diane sherman's name
written on the back
at nightfall before chloe goes to sleep
she is given some of the same medicine
as the night before
but this time chloe does not swallow the
green pill and takes it back to be
examined
after her mother is asleep chloe
immediately goes downstairs to finds
information about trigoxin through her
computer
unfortunately the browser can't be
accessed because there is an internet
problem
while using the computer chloe doesn't
realize that someone is watching her in
the corner of the room
the next day chloe immediately calls
random people
and asks that person to use the internet
and check the trigoxin listed on the
medicine package
it turns out that trigoxin is indeed a
medicine for the heart but strangely
phygoxin is a red pill not green chloe
begins to suspect her mother is up to
something
chloe is still very curious so she asks
her mother to go to the cinema
as an excuse to find information there
while at the cinema
chloe tells diane that she wants to go
to the toilet chloe leaves the cinema
and goes straight to the nearest
pharmacy when she arrives at the place
it turns out to be a very long queue
chloe immediately asked the person in
the queue to let her cut the queue
she questions the pharmacist about the
green medicine given by her mother
she asks what's the use of trigoxin the
pharmacist sees the drug and is confused
the drug is not trigoxin it is ritocane
the drug is usually used for dogs
chloe is shocked to hear this revelation
her world is thrown upside down
she then asks what will happen if humans
take the drug the pharmacist says
if people take this drug then the person
will experience paralysis
suddenly diane comes in panic and
immediately injects an anesthetic
into chloe's leg causing this revelation
to come to an abrupt end
her mother takes her home later at the
house
diane starts to panic so she locks chloe
in her room
and she goes out to buy a new paralytic
prescription that she has been looking
for
on the internet chloe wakes up and
realizes that her mother locks her in
the room
chloe is a smart teenager so she has a
few tricks to unlock the door
unfortunately her mother had anticipated
this and put the broom handle to bar the
door
but chloe doesn't give up so easily
chloe uses her scientific and technical
skills
and takes a solder blanket and holds
water in her mouth
she then comes out of the window and
crawls on the roof of her house to go to
the next room
as the suspense builds she uses the heat
from the solder
and then the water to break the glass in
the next room's window the blanket is
used as a placemat so that chloe's body
is not exposed to broken glass
after getting out of the window she
feels her asthma flare up and
unfortunately
she forgets to bring her inhaler chloe
is then trying to crawl with a shaky
breath to reach her room
arriving in her room she immediately
uses her inhaler to relieve her asthma
on time
chloe immediately gets into her
wheelchair and rushes to run away from
her house
however the elevator that khloe used to
go down the stairs has been damaged by
her mother
she then desperately throws the
wheelchair and crawls down the stairs
until suddenly
she slips and rolls down when she falls
chloe feels a miracle
she can feel and moves her toe because
she has not taken the medicine her
mother had given her for a long time
she becomes increasingly convinced that
her mother is a psychopath
chloe immediately gets into her
wheelchair and out of her house through
the road used to go to the city
suddenly chloe hears the sound of a car
coming chloe is afraid it is her
mother's car and immediately hides
it turns out that the vehicle is the
postman who used to deliver letters to
chloe's house
chloe then immediately rushes out of
hiding to block the postman's van until
she is almost hit
the postman gets out of his van and asks
what is wrong with chloe
chloe just says help me when the postman
is helping chloe her mother's car
suddenly passes and she sees the two of
them
diane immediately approaches the postman
who asks what happens to chloe
the postman stops diane who wants to
take her child home
the postman says that chloe doesn't want
to go home and wants to go to the police
station
diane persists in bringing her daughter
back home even threatening to report the
kidnapping to the police
because there is no signal diane's
efforts are in vain
she unwillingly lets the postman take
chloe away but on the condition that she
comes to
when chloe is being taken into the
postman's van diane stabs an anesthetic
into the postman's neck until he faints
chloe is also sedated until she faints
when she wakes up
chloe is already in the basement of her
house and locked up in it
chloe sees a black liquid made by her
mother which is probably a paralyzing
drug for her
chloe is unable to get away the
wheelchair can't move
because her mother had chained it chloe
then looks for a way to get out of there
until chloe sees that there is a pile of
paper it turns out to be a notification
regarding chloe's admission to the
university she had previously registered
for
chloe who knows that her mother had
hidden the paper from her looks
frustrated and annoyed
the revelation continues chloe finds
several photos showing that chloe used
to be healthy and not paralyzed
and even more surprising chloe sees a
paper containing a note of the death of
a baby named chloe
who died two hours after being born
along with a newspaper containing news
of a baby kidnapping at the same place
same time as chloe's death date at that
time chloe realizes that she is not
diane's biological child
and she is the child who was stolen from
her biological parents
it is revealed that dianne's baby shown
at the beginning of the film was not
saved
and because of that diane became so
frustrated that she kidnapped someone
else's baby in the hospital
to replace her dead baby when chloe is
stressed and confused
diane arrives she tells her that she is
not really her mother
and that she has also made chloe sick
and paralyzed all this time with
medication
diane says she did this because she
loves chloe she tells chloe to forget
all this and go back to how it used to
be
throwing away chloe's medication chloe
who is still afraid
refuses her mother's words until her
patience runs out
diane then takes the black liquid
mixture using a syringe to inject it
into chloe
chloe is getting more and more
frightened she immediately runs behind a
cupboard and locks it
chloe finds a poison and when her mother
manages to open the door
chloe immediately drinks the poison
until she overdoses
diane weeps very loudly seeing her
daughter dying from the poison
here it can be concluded that diane
loves chloe so much
that she wants to control every moves
that chloe makes since birth
but the question i ask you is this
really love or a selfish love
now chloe who is poisoned is immediately
taken to the hospital for medical
treatment
but fortunately chloe is successfully
cured by the doctors there
but she still finds it very difficult to
move and talk
chloe sees her mother staring at her
through the glass in chloe's room
chloe who sees this immediately asks for
help from the nurse in her room
by pressing the help button chloe can't
speak yet
so she can only signal through her eyes
the nurse gives chloe a note and crayon
so she can write something
down when chloe is forming a word a
sudden emergency alarm is sounded
it turns out the emergency alarm is a
sabotage carried out by diane to attract
the attention of the nurse who takes
care of chloe
not long after diane enters chloe's room
and immediately pulls out all chloe's
medical equipment
and takes her out after the nurse
returns to chloe's room
she is confused by chloe's disappearance
the nurse sees the note written by chloe
that reads
mom the nurse immediately reports this
to security to find chloe
chloe is brought forcefully by her
mother she can't ask for help
when she is almost out of the hospital
on the escalator chloe's mother can't
move chloe's wheelchair
it turns out that chloe uses her legs to
hold the wheelchair in place
yes here chloe's legs can be moved a
little
before long the security guards come to
stop them from leaving
seeing this diane immediately points a
gun at the security officer saying that
she just wants to go home with her child
one of the security guards manages to
shoot diane and she falls down the
stairs
chloe is rescued and diane is safely
secured by the authorities
the scene then moves seven years later
in a mental hospital chloe who is now an
adult
is shown to be able to move her legs
though it is still a struggle for her
there chloe is visiting someone who
turns out to be diane sherman
chloe says that her life now with her
real family is very pleasant
she has many friends and she has even
graduated from her favorite
university before chloe says goodbye she
seems to take something out of her mouth
which turns out to be the dog medicine
that diane had given her
chloe then says i love you mom now open
wide
that concludes the ending of the movie
run subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out
thank you for watching